what is the Apple Vision Pro
is it as dark and scary and dystopian as
you think it is yes here are the five
things that you need to know about
[Music]
on the surface the new Apple Vision Pro
seems like just the latest major leap
forward toward a devilish techno
dystopia in which we're all just fodder
inputs for a matrix like Borg and it is
it is that
but it's it's not all terrible well it's
all terrible but there are improvements
to society that would come out of the
Apple Vision Pro
ultimately it'll make Society worse but
in one way at least it would make
Society better which is that
it's bigger and more comprehensive than
your iPhone or your iPad or your
computer
and that's kind of a good thing
you you put the goggles on and
you see everything you see your apps and
you see your messages and you see the
thing you're watching and you see past
it and you see the people in the room
and you and you're sitting up and you've
got good posture
when I've got this stupid little thing
I've just I'm hunched over this all day
well I'm not because I don't answer
people's texts or emails or I'm actually
not on my phone very much at all but
most people aren't even I I Doom scroll
on Twitter or whatever and you find your
whole life is just in this what is it
five inch by three inch kind of box and
you're hunched over and it's very very
unhuman
so if instead you put the goggles on you
can sit up and look around and see the
whole world you can have them on while
you're walking you're not just stuck on
your little cubicle on your little couch
Doom scrolling I guess that would in a
way be an improvement now the bad side
is
that it's bigger and more comprehensive
and takes up your whole field of vision
make up your mind dude that's the bad
side because you can never get away from
him at least with this stupid little
thing I can just throw it across the
room or I can turn it on silent as I do
for much of the day at least with my
computer I can close it and then go sit
out in the world with the with the
goggles
is just on all the time it's all there
so you're never away
from a screen
and you might say well okay that's good
that means I can get my notifications
faster or I can communicate with people
across the world more easily or I can
see products or watch movies or or
scroll through videos even more easily
yeah all of that's true and you're also
going to pay much less attention to
what's going on in the real world
it adds another layer
between you and reality that's the third
thing that I notice about these goggles
and we don't need any more layers
between us in reality because we have so
many physical layers between us and
reality now in Modern Life we're very
often in climate controlled rooms in
climate controlled buildings in very
manicured cities where we don't
get to see the stars at night because of
light pollution where we don't get too
use our bodies very much we don't get to
walk around a lot we have all sorts of
health problems because of that we don't
get to see the beauty of a pasture or an
ocean or walk through a garden or any
because we're just kind of locked in our
own cramped little apartments in our own
cramped little pods whatever right so
this
adds another layer between us and
reality in many ways it's an answer to
Psalm 8 in Psalm 8 the psalmist says oh
you know I'm looking all around the
earth the overhanging firmament you
created this world for me god wow how
wonderful it is what is man that he
should deserve this
[Music]
what the goggles do is they say hey do
you want to live in that big beautiful
majestical world that God created for
you or would you rather live in a screen
that Tim Cook made for you and because
this is a Fallen World in the
imagination of man's heart is evil from
the very beginning a lot of people are
going to choose the latter which is
unfortunate and what are we going to see
in the ladder we're still going to see
the stuff in our room but then we're
going to see apps and we're certainly
going to see products that we can buy
this is probably the worst part of it
this is the fourth thing I observe about
the Vision Pro is that it will further
waste your time and it will further
transform you from a creative individual
into a passive consumer
because you know the thing that's being
sold right now about the goggles is that
you can watch movies and big screen and
and it's really clever the way they do
that because
there are two ways to see a movie on a
big screen you can either make a really
gigantic expensive screen in a huge
space where you'd have to basically have
a movie theater in your house a big IMAX
movie theater in your house or
you can bring the screen really close to
your eyes and so it looks bigger in your
field of vision and that's less
expensive and much easier to do given
the constraints of where people live and
they're going to say you can watch
movies you can watch documentaries you
can communicate with people but what's
the other thing that you're going to do
you're going to buy stuff and you're
gonna be able to buy stuff with your
eyes you're going to use your hands
you're just going to look and you're
going to say oh Amazon app
or Apple Store
buy blink if you want to spend 10 bucks
on some stupid episode yeah sure
just give me more stuff that I blink if
you want to get some I don't know
handbag delivered bling oh yeah please
bye bye bye you're gonna do that until
all your money runs that money is good
but not only are you gonna be buying all
this stuff most of which you don't need
but there's an opportunity cost for all
of that time
time really matters you know time is
money baby and so
all of the time that you're spending
watching these movies and engaging in
social media and chats and stuff that
you're already doing now you'll just be
doing a much more immersive way
it's time that you could have spent
working at your job time that you could
have spent praying remember praying
remember when people would pray time
that you could have spent learning a
musical instrument time that you could
have spent walking through your
neighborhood time that you could have
spent with your actual Neighbors in your
actual Community time they could have
spent doing things that are productive
building that toy for your kid that you
ordered or making some memory with your
family it's going to take you away from
that
and those things are not merely
pleasurable in themselves but they they
also have a much longer payoff if you
learn how to play the ukulele when
you're a kid
then someday when you're old you're
going to have something that gives you
enjoyment
and even when you're young you're gonna
have something that gives you enjoyment
you're never going to be bored if you
spend time reading books you're going to
cultivate all sorts of different
interests and ideas that are going to
occupy your time whereas if you instead
spend your time just passively consuming
things
then you're gonna get bored a lot you're
even going to get bored of the magical
goggles and so they're gonna have to
they're gonna have to increase the
stimulation which is what always happens
with modern technology so it's going to
be even more immersive and eventually
they're going to plug your brainstem
into the Matrix and then it's all going
to be lost then there's one final thing
that I notice about the goggles
also negative we had one kind of
positive four negatives here and it's
this curious little bit
about how while you're using the goggles
your avatar is going to speak with their
hands
as though all the avatars are Italian or
something you see it in the trailer that
that you're going to be making an
impassioned speech and it's going to
have your hand going like this and like
that and your face is going to be moving
you'll be smiling the AI is so smart
that it's going to know that when you
move your eyes in a certain way or when
you say a certain thing a certain volume
with a certain inflection that that's
the sort of thing
that you would say when you raised your
hands when you smiled or when you
frowned or it's gonna it's just gonna
know
and and there were two scary conclusions
we can draw from that
one is that the AI actually does know
that you are predictable that we're
feeding this thing so much data all the
time that it actually knows us better
than we know ourselves the other nasty
conclusion that we could draw from it is
that it's making these decisions for us
yeah maybe you didn't literally raise
your hands when you were having that
conversation and making that point but
your avatar did and you probably would
have
right it would make sense for you to do
that so it's just going to decide to do
that for you and the whole point of
these goggles is to be more and more
immersive the technology companies now
are just competing for more and more of
our attention and the the limit on that
the ideal will be 24 hours a day
I guess ultimately the real limit is
radical life extension where they figure
out how to somehow upload your brain
into a cloud or some some other
science fiction craziness so that they
can really get you forever and just mine
you for juice forever but that's what
they want they want you to be spending
more and more of your life there they
want you to have business meetings there
they want you to watch movies there they
want you to hang out with your friends
there they want you to play games there
they want you oh you're definitely going
to look at a ton of porn there right I
mean that porn is ubiquitous in our
culture it drives so much technological
advancement the vast majority of people
look at it regularly I mean the minute
that you pair these goggles with some
sex robot that I'm sure they're going to
develop tomorrow then we're never
reproducing again then civilization is
actually over the human race is probably
over at that point but but even put all
of that aside
it's going to be
for all intents and purposes in public
life
you
and so if the public representation of
is having decisions made by a computer
and that means that you are no longer
really
in control
a cart
is coming before the horse
the tail is wagging the dog
and your sunglasses are controlling you
and you look like a big weirdo nerd
while you're doing it
so now I probably won't buy them until
in this techno dystopia they just make
us all do it
in which case because it sounds so dark
and scary and obviously inhuman I have
to assume it's going to happen and I
guess I'll see you all there
with with a bunch of arms making weird
Italian gestures
in the metaverse
see ya
[Music]